time for today's speed round brought to
you by verizon 5g
built right peter king mike florio
working our way through this friday
edition of pft live let's get into it
for this weekend's games either game
pick a name which receiver must be held
in check peter
i think stefan diggs more than any
single receiver
you might say
devonte adams and i would understand
that but the way
that uh that aaron rodgers has spread
the ball around recently i i won't say
that but i will say that stefan diggs is
hugely hugely
important for the kansas city chiefs
they know that i think they're going to
try to be physical with them early try
to get him off his game a little bit
stefan diggs is my is my guy who's who
they have to hold in check to win this
game
you know i went through the same process
devonte adams was the first name that
came to mind but then it's like you
can't hold him in check you just have to
accept the fact he's going to get the
ball and he's going to get his yards and
maybe get a touchdown or two you have to
deal with that with diggs i just feel
like if someone fully commits to taking
him away that's the keystone
to possibly collapsing the bill's
offense especially because we've seen
over the years stefan diggs can get
frustrated he can get a little yes antsy
the in the game against the chiefs when
they were losing and they're trying to
get the ball down the field and they're
trying to move to the line of scrimmage
he's walking back to the line of
scrimmage you want him to snap a little
bit if you're the chiefs and you do it
with physicality keep him from getting
into his route keeping him from getting
the football build a lead he gets
frustrated and then the bills have that
to worry about on top of everything else
that should be the goal for the chief's
defense not just take digs away but make
him frustrated because that could
implode the whole offense
defensive player who will get picked on
the most this weekend peter who you got
um this was a tough one to choose from
because normally you get to this level
and you don't have a lot of weak points
but my feeling is what the
green bay packers are going to try to do
in this game is they're going to try to
make aaron jones hugely important and i
think what they're going to try to do is
run at jason pierre paul's side of the
tampa defense jason pierre-paul
desperately wants to be a pass rush
force in this game i think they're going
to try to be physical against pierre
paul and take their chances with running
at him
you know i think that makes a ton of
sense because as sims and i have been
saying you can't run it outside devin
white and levante david are going to
gobble you up if you do and now that
vida veya i don't know how healthy he is
and i don't know if this is more of a
play for the super bowl not for the
conference championship game but there
are going to be limited windows and if
the green bay packers are going to have
any success running the football they
got to find a weakness they got to find
an opening and it may be
jpp trying to get around the edge to to
get after aaron rodgers that creates an
opening to run and also if you start
running at him what do you do you
neutralize jpp as uh as a pass rusher
because he's thinking that aaron jones
is going to be coming right at him or
jamal williams or aj dylan if dylan's
able to play which assistant coach has
the most important job
and my feeling is brian dabel uh the
offensive coordinator of the bills just
keep two things in mind
brian dabal doesn't have a great running
game to rely on right now you know
you know i would say that the three
other coaches
in this game
all have a better running game that they
can rely on this week than the offensive
coordinator of the buffalo bills and
what that means is
you know it's second and five now and
dabo mentally might be thinking well
it's a passing down you know it's not
necessarily a running down and
so i think dabol has got to get it into
the head of his quarterback who you know
and you just don't know maybe get shaken
if they get behind by 10 early and get
it in the head of his quarterback okay
okay let's take small chunks dawson knox
cole beasley short stuff intermediate
point of the field don't get greedy
brian dabol has to be disciplined in
this game and his offense has to be
disciplined
you ever try to start a chainsaw in the
cold i have a feeling peter king has
never tried to start a chainsaw in the
cold
never never in my life okay i've never
even said i've never even started a
chainsaw mike i just chopped down the
trees myself with an axe
what the packer what the buccaneers
excuse me are going to need on sunday is
todd bowles to start that defense which
is a chainsaw in the cold because
when you wake them up
they are incredible and we saw them
finally wake up in the second half of
the game against the saints but it's on
todd bowles the buccaneers defensive
coordinator to get those guys and maybe
he can get it going right out of the
gates maybe it's on the first pull that
it gets going but that's the thing he's
got to get his guys
throwing caution to the wind playing
with reckless abandon i think devon
white is basically the cord on the
chainsaw because we saw it from him in
the first half of the game against the
saints it just didn't really spread
that's the key though if they want to
win this game they have to slip back
into that zone that we saw that defense
slip into in the second half of the
saints game that's the only way they're
going to crack the code on aaron rodgers
because he he's otherwise going to pick
him apart and it's going to become a
shootout and i think the packers win a
shootout if it becomes a shootout
between green bay and tampa bay which
home field advantage will be more
impactful
on sunday
i mean i don't want to be cliche but
obviously green bay and not just because
of the cold this is the first time aaron
rodgers has ever played a championship
game at home i think that is it's hugely
important to him
and he's not going to he's not going to
freeze up over it no pun intended
he's gonna play as aaron rodgers does
and i think that is important and and
look you'd be stupid not to mention that
there's so many guys on that tampa bay
team
who are warm weather players from warm
weather colleges and you said it earlier
in the show mike you know don't give me
all this stuff about how the cold
doesn't matter it matters
once you get that first taste of it it
matters and everything you try to do to
get yourself
mentally prepared for it goes away the
other reason i think the packers have
more of a home field advantage this is
only their second game with fans present
and they say there's only 6 500
i
i don't know if they're wearing a lot of
layers or what it looks like more than 6
500 people in the stands and the the
i know that the packers struggled
throughout the regular season without
having that external source of energy
and i think that gives the packers
another advantage as well the chiefs
have had their 15 000 all year they're
used to it for the packers it's still
new should patriots fans be rooting
for
the buccaneers and hashtag tommy or the
green bay packers to keep tommy from
getting to a super bowl without the
patriots and bill belichick
personally i think if you're a real
patriots fan you're rooting for tom
brady
because
how can you not root for a guy who has
given you more
sporting joy and maybe more life joy
than you've ever had
following any sport
so to me it would be pretty small
if you say well he doesn't play here
anymore so i hope he loses i mean come
on
this was a this was a joint decision
believe me uh that tom brady isn't there
anymore and so it it if i'm a patriots
fan i'm rooting for brady to get number
seven
i talked to tom kern about this earlier
in the week he said that the patriots
fans are split between the belichick
files and the brady files and the folks
who align with belichick don't want
brady to win they don't want brady to
make belichick look bad and and i think
at a certain level you can make the
argument even though it is small and
petty it's you know people are small and
petty and i'm as small and petty as
anyone you don't want to diminish your
legacy of six super bowls by having your
quarterback go win one somewhere else
because then you start thinking well
maybe it was more the quarterback than
the coach or the team or the patriot way
uh so i could see plenty of patriots
fans
thinking go pack go on sunday when tom
brady comes to town all right let's take
a mic let me just say one thing
let me let me say one thing about that
the world is going to be a better place
when we stop asking the following
question
so who's more responsible brady or
belichick for the patriots greatness i
mean
can't we simply accept the fact
no matter who we root for no matter who
we love no matter who who we hate can't
we just simply accept the fact that some
people are better together than apart
and i can't just accept the fact it's a
great mystery of sport
you will never know this you can come up
with every argument you want belichick's
under 500 without brady brady is this
belichick is that whatev whatever you
come up with i don't care
i appreciate the fact that in my 37-year
career covering the national football
league i got to cover one of the best
sports teams of all time
the new england patriots and you know
what
they had one of the greatest coaches of
all time and they have one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time and
let's just not try to say oh well
belichick's better than brady
i don't care
see if i were a real smart ass this is
the point where i would ask you
who's more responsible for the patriots
super bowl success brady or belichick
but i won't let's take a break i would
say gerard mayo
show me something draft coming up next
here on bft live
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon 5g built right
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports